we are with the head lady in charge one
who is running the show for you as chest
Jean welcome back to the show great to
be here Jean we know there are these are
exciting times for chess in the United
States the sink filled Cup all these in
credit the millionaire chests open if I
have to Pat myself on the back lots of
youth activities a real surge in in
scholastic chess what has led to all
this especially under your leadership
the time that you've been there you know
the growth and the excitement that we're
experiencing right now is something that
has I think's been building over the
years and it's due to the hard work of
chess players organizers throughout the
country I think you definitely have to
point out some of the specific things
that have come out of the chest capital
the United States st. Louis again
Sinfield cup for three years now has
energized the chess world by bringing
world-class strongest wrestlers in the
world here to the United States now with
the announcement the grantchester it
goes global this is you know these are
exciting times this is amazing it is
amazing it's awesome and also the
digital era just chess just marrying
quite well with that give me some
specifics on the initiatives that US
chess is taking the Chess Federation is
taking right now I know you have a new
website I saw that looks very nice we
did so earlier it this year in August we
launched a new visual identity which
included a new homepage new design it's
a part of a multi-year multi long-term
project to improve our website we also
introduced a new logo and a new identity
as us chess um lots of exciting stuff
going on and it will continue to see
improvements on throughout the year
we're thrilled a shout out to Jim bula
who did your website yeah um June below
we have worked with me actually our
website was designed by Trey and rocket
lifts
okay thanks for the correction so what
do you see as as the big plan what's the
win here it is it is it more kids
playing chess is it more adults as it
just bringing adults back into the game
and that's been a challenge as we've
seen the growth of scholastic chess the
adult so you know may not have been so
excited how do we get them back well you
know that's actually one exciting area
of growth that we've started to see just
in the past two years is that with young
adult membership that is increasing and
that's an area again where traditionally
we've seen that retention rates drop as
kids get older but for the young adult
group to grow that's where we want to be
going um I think you know as US chess
our mission is to empower people through
chess one move at a time and we want to
reach everyone so we want to focus on
kids we want to focus on adults focus on
seniors there's you know and there's
lots of ways to do that I know that you
moved your office here to st. Louis how
do you like it living I believe you live
in the central west end now what is that
like as a stone's throw away from all
this exciting chess all the time oh it's
been great you know st. Louis truly has
emerged as the capital press capital of
the United States and there's always so
many exciting things going on at the
chest campus but you know throughout the
city I think there's just been the city
of st. Louis has exhibited a type of
commitment to chess that serves as an
example for other cities um your if you
go to any of these events you'll notice
that mayor slay makes a commitment to
come be a part of it that's fantastic
that's what we need that's that's the
kind of support and partnerships that we
need to develop in other cities in the
United States absolutely look well let's
hope that we can replicate that in other
cities around the country thanks so much
Tina Hoffman for all the work you do
thank you for having me gene Hoffman the
head lady in charge of us chest doing
great work as chest appears and is
definitely
getting a resurgence here in the United
States